ich liebe es dass leute auf youtube
verfolgen können was ich mache was ich
aber noch mehr leben würde wäre wenn
leute mein zeug auch noch außerhalb von
youtube sehen könnten zum beispiel in
einem museum museum also habe ich einen
plan geschmiedet innerhalb von drei
tagen ein paar bilder gemalt und die
einfach selber hin zum museum der
engpass für pilger ich gemalt habe mit
wem ich die bilder gemalt habt wie ich
dir ins museum bekommen habe und ob sie
bis heute im museum hängen erfahrt ihr
im laufe des videos als allererstes muss
sich natürlich damit starten mir
irgendeinen plan zu machen grundsätzlich
immer wenn ich irgendwas mit kunst
bisher auf meinem kanal gemacht habe
habe ich mir hilfe dazu geholt also
dachte ich dass es dieses mal auch
wieder schlau wäre damit die bilder
einfach nicht aussehen wie von einem
grundschüler gemalt und jody hat sich
glücklicherweise wieder mal zeit für
mich genommen
danke sehr wird schon so als würden wir
jetzt da das anfang dabei haben wir
eigentlich fast alles fertig haben vor
ein paar tagen schon mal gemeinsam
gemalt und jetzt finalisieren
die sache wird sind ja respektable
künstler weil die möglichst lange in
diesem museum screen und für jeden fall
von 500 euro
ich mag es ja so aus dem gefühl ich bin
ein künstler muss mir da gar keine lang
gedanken oder machen das ist einfach der
lift läuft von alleine toni wie reich
wird man eigentlich mit oli fällt vom
cap ist da nicht so gut für einen gewinn
künftig ich bin echt gespannt was es mir
schon vorstellen dass die das echt nicht
so geil finden
das erstmal die ganzen konturen haben
aber wenig noch drei berufe nicht mich
treiben lasse ist drogen und
alkoholsucht der das leben eines
künstlers noam so hart um gleich schon
wieder fertig mit arbeiten dann ist nur
in der kreativität heute raten bilde ich
mir halt so schwer
ich habe komplett verkackt du bist ein
wunderkind
es gibt keinen plan sieht nur fahren am
ufer der ist doch so ganz einig muss
natürlich dass samuel im museum machen
man sieht das immer shrek im hintergrund
und dann eben mein bild ich glaube nicht
dass bilder neben ein bisschen parade
teams
[Musik]
krass wie man mit einem mit einem
glückstreffer sein leben genießen
habe ich auch nicht geklaut ganz kurzen
start gehen vielen dank dass du mich
immer dabei unterstützt endlich etwas
mit kunst machen will obwohl es
überhaupt nicht im prinzip ist es
scheißegal was wir machen weil geht
vielmehr darum dass wir es illegal
reinhängen
audi macht hier und ich bin dann dafür
dass da das gesetz zu brechen und das
bild reinzuhängen danke corporation's ob
die nation
[Applaus]
also ja das kilo die hat hier ihren
signature hasen einmal oder ist da komm
ich würde sagen das ist das einfach nur
ein job
die langen drei stunden zweifel weil die
kreativität kommt schnell aus mir raus
und dann ist ja schnell erschöpft
deswegen muss jetzt schnell wieder
schiesser woche nicht ich weiß nur noch
nicht im web und auf drei museen gibt wo
das überhaupt in irgendeiner weise rein
passt und den ausstellungen haben aber
da wollen die verkaufen und und
fallrohre fremdkörper ausstellung ist
ein gutes stichwort denn ich habe mich
schon zweites video überlegt es wird
komplett gestört da werde ich auch
wieder aussichtslos
die bilder würden definitiv in dem
museum hängen und dann musste ich nur
noch im museum raussuchen ich hab
gedacht wahrscheinlich wäre es das
schlimmste wenn ich das museum nehme das
am besten überwacht ist und wo die
meisten leute hingehen museum für
angewandte kunst super viele sehr
wichtige geschichtsträchtige gemälde und
so da aus bauhauszeit deswegen habe ich
auch so dreieck und viereck und reise
und so gemacht mal wenn ich leuten von
der idee erzählt habe ist genau eine
frage aufgekommen wie zur hölle willst
du die gemälde da rein bekommen
na gut so schwer war das nicht
genauso laufe ich dann rein und dann
hänge ich das auch mit pata fix oder so
wie wir meinen eltern zu erklären warum
es schlau für mich ist nicht weiter zu
studieren wird los 5 kommt in die hose
damit 2 ist schon kritisch macht er gut
und ich darf mich halt nicht bluten weil
sonst ja und jetzt museum für das war
wirklich klasse als gedacht also in
jedem winkel in der kamera wirklich in
jedem und auf zwei besucher kam eine
security person es war halt 35 grad
draußen es war niemand im museum außer
bier und eine andere gruppe wir wurden
auf schritt und tritt verfolgt wirklich
schritt und tritt eine person war immer
hinter uns
[Musik]
es würde sich schon gut hier ein rein
es schien komplett aussichtslos deswegen
haben uns überlegt wir laufen erst mal
richtung toilette um an einem neuen plan
zu feiern der neue plan war dann ein
neben die toilette zu helfen so konnte
wenigstens ein bild im museum schon mal
safe platzieren das problem war dass
dann da auf den security typ kam also
ich weiß nicht was die ganzen gemälde
und ausgestellten dinge da wert sind
aber man hat sich bedroht gefühlt wie in
nordkorea
man wurde komplett überwacht hat
wirklich zwischenzeitlich gedacht dass
es für mich unmöglich ist da irgendwas
aufzuhalten nach anderthalb stunden auf
und ab laufen im museum habe ich meinen
ganzen mut zusammengenommen noch einmal
nach links und nach rechts geschaut und
das gemälde aufgehängt
[Musik]
plötzlich ging mein bild das ich
innerhalb von zwei stunden mit johnny
silver gemalter aber damit es nicht
komplett scheiße wird inmitten und
diesen unendlich teuren kaz überwachten
mega gemälde selbst eins also
erfolgreich gemeistert die große frage
die man sich dann so stellen könnte wäre
wie lange bleibt zum gemälde hängen
fällt das komplett auf der reihe oder
könnten die leute die durch laufen auch
denken das ist einfach komplett dazu
gehören den ersten fünf minuten ist gar
nichts passiert das bild ist kommen
vielleicht hängen geblieben wir sind
noch mal ein bisschen drumrum gelaufen
und haben gesehen dass einfach nichts
passiert also niemand hat uns über die
kamera beobachtet und es ist nicht
direkt aufgefallen darüber nachdenken
habe ich dann aber so viel schiss
bekommen dass sich ungerne selber
nochmal ins museum gehen wollte um nicht
mit irgendwem konfrontiert zu werden der
sich an mich erinnern konnte also habe
ich mag's freundin hingeschickt lager
hat angerufen
die ist für mich ins museum gegangen um
zu gucken auf meinen linken seite schon
im zweiten stock
es hängt nicht von lätta hängt noch 1
eine schande vier tage später das
gemälde hängt nicht mehr
man muss auch dazu sagen dass ich es
vielleicht nicht ganz gerade aufgehängt
hat sondern das so leicht schräg war war
alles in allem war das doch ein voller
erfolg haben coole bilder gemalt wir
haben zwei davon im museum platzieren
können die waren zwar weiter nach drei
oder vier tagen schon wieder weg aber es
hat zumindest für ein paar tage
funktioniert und ich hoffe ich konnte
euch in den letzten minuten gut
unterhalten lassen ihn leichter wenn
euch das video gefallen hat abonniert
und kein video mehr zu verpassen
wir sehen uns in den nächsten tagen